او كمدخل ايضا
لحظات الاولى تلقيتي فيها خبر اختيارك
كرائده فضاء سعوديه
نعيش معاك هذا الجو وكيف كانت رده الفعل
بالنسبه لك والله يا استاذ حسن كان
بالنسبه لي يوم استثنائي في حياتي يعني
يوم ما تلقيت الخبر انا الى الان اعجز اني
الاقي كلمات توصف شعوري هذاك الوقت حماس
تفاؤل
فخر اعتزاز يعني
بحاجه احسها تفوق الوصف يعني
احس كاني اتذكر موقف كانه صار امس يعني
كنت مستعده لابسه الباطل البالط حق
المختبر حقي وخلاص طالعه من البيت رايحه
على دوامي
اتصال يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء السعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه لان الان رائده فضاء او باحثه ما
صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحكم عملي
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا اسكن في
الرياض واهلي في جده فاحد الاشخاص اللي
مهمين بالنسبه لي هي ستي ام الوالده كنت
حابه اني انا اقول لها الخبر وهي في جده
فطلعت على الغرفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلبت يوم اجازه واخذت تذكره من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها هذا الخبر
العظيم